It's a clue,
but he voted for Jean-Luc
Mélenchon indeux-mille-vingt-deux,
hmm,
we'll say 4,
but possibility to make up for it on certain topics.
It's indicative,
but he participated in the riots
ofdeux-mille-vingt-trois,
ouch.
Oh no,
that's 1 0,
that's 1 10.
But he participated in the demonstration against
police violence
a few days ago,
it's 1,
1 5.
And when he needs the police,
the change.
It's 1 10,
but he eats meat every day.
Ah,
I really like meat,
but you don't have to.
So we'll say,
it's 1 egg,
we'll degrade it 1 little bit.
It is 1 10.
But it is propotine
if it is for reasons to be mean,
uh,
it goes down to 4 hands.
It's 1 10.000.
Will Macron win in the second round
to block Marine Le Pen,
ouch,
um, well,
it's 1, 2,
it's 1 10. But
the National Rally is not Republican.
Lack of reading.
So uh, it's 1,
6, huh,
It can be made up for too.
It's 1 10. But he is vegan,
yeah, it passes,
no,
that can stay 1 10,
it's 1 10.
But it reads a lot of megabat.
Oh no,
but as long as he reads,
uh, it remains 1 10,
it's 1 10.
But he watches a lot of his news,
well it's ok,
it remains 1 10